[Musique]
regardez ces sommes des hommes pour qui
chaque minute valent de l'or leurs
maîtres mots rentabiliser alors pour
cela il avale jambon beurre en deux
temps trois mouvements constat la salle
de gym entre deux rendez vous c'est un
faux bois pour quelques foulées batterie
mais c'est une honte un véritable
massacre
que de temps perdu il suffit de lever la
tête tenait un feu rouge du style en
moyenne une bonne minute 20 on peut
grappiller à l'arrêt d'autobus au moins
trois minutes quant aux taxis quand au
niveau chip pas saouler on poireaute
cinq minutes formule hommes et hervé
lewis ont donc décidé que vous remettre
dans le droit chemin de la rentabilité
hervé lewis était l'entraîneur des stars
la forme du mylène farmer c'est lui les
dix kilos de muscles supplémentaires de
jean reno dans le grand bleu c'est
encore lui et les muscles de johnny il
s'en chargent aussi aujourd'hui il
s'occupe du vous abribus on peut
travailler les bras on peut travailler
également les dorsaux alors pour les
bras il ya deux prises différentes on
peut prendre comme ça si on veut
travailler un peu plus les biceps et
dans l'autre sens si on travaille un peu
plus ses avant bras et une prise très
large en faisant passer la barre
derrière la tête pour travailler les
dorsaux on va voir l'exercice tout suite
ce serait bien de souffler par exemple
dans cet exercice quand tu montes
sauf
[Musique]
ce petit exercice favorise d'étirements
de l'arrière du mollet également un peu
du tendon d'achille et c'est un très bon
exercice qu'on peut faire comme ça sur
un beau une bordure de trottoir un petit
peu n'importe où alors on peut prendre
appui si on veut sur un poteau si on a
un peu le faire également sans appui
selon sa taille on prend un trottoir
plus ou moins élevés donc c'est
relativement facile à trouver dans la
ville il n'y a pas de problème c'est
bien à faire avant le jogging après son
jogging
on peut s'en servir par exemple après
avoir joué au tennis avant de jouer au
tennis tous les sports de jambes c'est à
dire ça peut être le foot ça peut être
le tennis tous les sports qui est qui
ont tendance à comment dire qu'ils ont
tendance à a noué un petit peu les
jambes
victime d'un banc pour pour étirer les
fessiers pourrait tirer toujours pareil
dans dix ans l avantage du mans tu te
fais un travail un petit peu de
musculation un petit peu étirements et
échauffement également et ça attire un
petit peu une zone plus haute c'est à
dire plutôt l'arrière deux cuisses et le
fessier
[Musique]
le dernier tuyaux vous intéressera tous
stressés fatigués et énervé que vous
n'êtes pas besoin de pilule ou de
vitamines pour ce truc d'hervé lewis
contre le coup de pompe un costume une
cravate et une moquette suffit
l'exercice consiste gea se lever de son
bureau
prendre un petit break s'allongent et
les pieds contre le mur m quelque chose
sur les yeux éventuellement sa cravate
par exemple de manière à faire un peu
l'obscurité faire quelques respirations
profondes pas trop violemment et des
expirations doivent être beaucoup plus
lente
voilà
voilà un exercice qui peut être fait
très simplement au bureau qui peut durer
de 30 secondes à quatre cinq voire dix
minutes et qui s'il est bien fait et
équivaut à deux heures de sommeil
profond qui permet donc une très bonne
récupération très bonne récupération de
l'influx nerveux donc une détente au
niveau du stress
[Musique]
récapitulons ils les abribus pour
muscler les avant bras
[Musique]
le coût du trottoir pour les petits
différement
[Musique]
et le banc pour échauffer musclé et
tirer beaucoup
[Musique]